From the moment she's born, a man's daughter is the center of his universe.
You give her love.
You give her encouragement.
You watch her grow into a strong, confident woman.
And then one day,...
...you come face-to-face with the love of her life.
The Flemings are in the house!
Yes!
Oh my God.
Well, looks like he works out quite a bit.
Stephie, get them up here!
Please be please.
Dad, on Christmas day, I'm gonna ask Stephie to marry me...
...and I'd really like your blessing.
Yeah.
No.
Just give me a couple days to win you over.
By Christmas morning, you're gonna be calling me "son",...
...I'm gonna be calling you "dad".
Don't think that's going to happen.
I think it's gonna, Dad.
I know it won't.
Dad, it will.
Stop that.
What, dad?
That, stop that.
Dad, what are you talking about?
Steph, you could be dating anyone.
Why Laird?
He makes me really happy.
He is wrapping his tentacles around every member of this family.
You're not going to say anything to Stephanie about the proposal, right?
Is that a drone?
Laird is spying on us.
What?
Do not mess with me!